in this video we're going to talk about
how to complete the square so if you're
given a quadratic like x squared plus 6x
minus seven equals zero and you want to
solve this equation by completing the
square the first step is to get the
variables on one side of the equation
and the numbers on the opposite side so
I'm going to do is I'm going to add 7 to
both sides of this equation and if we do
that we're left with x squared well 6x
equals 7 now what you want to do is you
want to take the coefficient the number
in front of the X to the first term and
you want to divide that by 2 and square
it so we take 6 divided by 2 and we
square that quantity so that's going to
be 3 squared which equals 9 so we want
to do is we want to add 9 to the left
side of the equation as well as to the
right side of the equation to keep it
balanced now what we can do is we can
factor this left side of the equation
and it's going to be a perfect square
and when you factor this is going to be
ax and it'll always be 1/2 of this
middle coefficient so half of 6 is going
to be positive 3 if this was minus 6x
then it would be negative 3 and that
equals 16 so now we've completed the
square the next part to solve it would
be then to take the square root of both
sides of the equation
and when you do that you get two answers
you get plus or minus 4 and this is
going to just be X plus 3 because the
square and the square root cancel so now
what you can do is you can go ahead and
split this into two equations so I would
write this as X plus 3 is equal to
positive 4 and X plus 3 is equal to
negative 4 so if we subtract 3 from both
sides we get x equals 1 and here if we
subtract 3 from both sides we get x
equals negative 7 and those are our two
solutions now that was an easy problem
because we had a leading coefficient of
1 but how would you do a little bit more
difficult problem say for example like
this
five x squared minus 10x minus 15 equals
zero
well BC this leading coefficient is five
in front what you want to do is you want
to divide everything by five okay so
this way it's a little bit easier to
complete the square so now you have x
squared minus two X minus three equals
zero I would move that constant to the
other side by doing the op so that would
add three so now we have x squared minus
two x equals three and then to complete
the square we take a half of that middle
coefficient half of that number in front
of the ax and we square it so sometimes
I like to do that work off to the side
so negative two divided by two and
squared so that's going to be negative
one squared which is equal to one so if
we add one to the left side we want to
keep that balance and add one to the
right side the left side of the equation
when we do this completing the square it
becomes a perfect square okay or a
binomial squared and the way you factor
that remember it's always going to be
half of that middle coefficient so in
this case instead of negative two we're
going to take half of that it's going to
be X minus 1 the quantity squared equals
four if you want to check your work you
can write this twice X minus one times X
minus one and foil it and you'll get
back to x squared minus 2x plus one
but now we've completed the square all
we need to do is take the square root of
both sides of the equation that's going
to give us remember two answers plus or
minus two the square and the square root
cancel and I'm going to show you another
method on this problem instead of
splitting it up into two equations what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to add one to
both sides of the equation and when I do
that what you're gonna see is that this
is going to be plus one plus one so
that's going to be x equals one plus or
minus two so notice I put that adding
one I put that plus one in front of the
plus or minus you don't want to put it
over here on the right and so now we
have two problems to solve one plus two
is of course three and one minus two is
negative one and those are going to be
our two solutions to that
one the third example I want to show you
now involves some fractions so a little
bit more challenging example we've got
negative 2x squared plus 5x minus 1
equals 0 and what we want to do here is
we want to again get that leading
coefficient to be positive 1 so I'm
going to divide everything by a negative
2 it makes it easier to complete the
square of course 0 divided by negative 2
is still going to be 0 this is going to
be 1/2 this is going to be negative 5
halves okay and then this is going to be
just these cancel it just gives us
positive x squared so now what I would
do is I would get the number on the
other side by subtracting 1/2 from both
sides of the equation and that's going
to give us x squared minus 5 halves
equals a negative 1/2 so here's the
completing the square part what we want
to do is we want to take half of
negative 5 over 2 and square it now when
you take half of something you can
divide it by 2 or you can multiply it by
1/2 so in this case this comes out to
negative 5/4 squared which is 25 16 so
we're going to add 25 16 to the right
side of the equation and we're going to
add 25 16 to the left side to keep it
balanced so now we just have to factor
the left side and remember when you
factor it's going to be a perfect square
so it's going to be X and then half of
this middle coefficient so it's gonna be
X minus 5 over 4 I just multiplied this
by 1/2 on the right side though we have
to get a common denominator so it looks
like if we multiply the numerator and
denominator by 8 that's going to give us
negative 8 16 plus 25 16 which is equal
to let's see 1716
now we've completed the square all we
need to do is solve by taking the square
root of both sides of the equation and
remember when you do that you get your
two answers of course square root of 17
we can't simplify but the square root of
16 is just going to be 4 and then here
the square and the square root cancel
one another out we just are left with X
minus 5/4 and the last thing to do now
is really just to get the X by itself so
I'm going to add five force to both
sides of the equation and remember what
you want to do is you want to put that
5/4 in front of the plus or minus so
it's going to be 5/4 plus or minus the
square root of 17 over 4 and you can do
this on your calculator or you can leave
it like this as an exact answer